a warning this report from Skies Becky
Johnson contains details which viewers
might find distressing
anything you do say may be given an
Evidence
on you you're right this is Ross
McCullum being arrested on suspicion of
kidnap after Megan nubra's family
reported she was missing
in a whispered voice he tells police
where he disposed of her body
Charlie Road whereabouts
in the library okay
is she alive
no
okay
all right you want to come with us
here here
officers sent to search the area soon
discovered he'd done exactly as he'd
said
Megan had left her home in nuneaton to
drive to SEMA Cullum they'd just begun a
relationship after meeting at work but
within 40 minutes of arriving at his
house here in Colville in leicestershire
she was dead
first mccollum's strangled Megan then he
took a knife and slit her throat 14
times later telling police he did so to
make sure she was dead he bundled her
body into the passenger seat of her own
car and drove off at the same time he
was sending text messages to her phone
to try to cover his tracks
after disposing of her body and phone in
remote Countryside he drove to
Loughborough and was captured on CCTV
changing his clothes and throwing them
away before taking a taxi home and
leaving this voice message on Megan's
phone
oh babe it's Ross um what I'm just
worried about you Kevin rang back
or you know text me or anything
um
no it's probably nothing can't be
friends together we fell asleep but uh
yeah I'm just worried that's all I had a
fun time earlier
um yeah anyway uh I'll see you tomorrow
okay
by lunchtime of the next day Megan's
family was so concerned they called
police
why is that Ross
my name
is me Ross McCullum pretended he too was
worried where she was
hello
um we've just gone to your mum and dad's
house and we're just looking for Megan
she's been reported missing have you
seen her at all she came on Friday
I've been trying to call alone we now
know he spent the hours after killing
Megan watching porn and Googling serial
killers I genuinely believe
um haven't investigated this
from the offset that Ross enjoyed
killing Megan I genuinely think that it
excited him and I genuinely believe that
potent he had the potential to kill
again from his actions afterwards they
certainly didn't show
signs of any remorse whatsoever
during the trial McCullum claimed he
killed Megan due to Blind rage after
remembering sexual abuse from his
childhood but the jury concluded that
Megan was murdered by a man she thought
she could trust Becky Johnson's Sky News